PARISA TABRIZ: All right, cool.
So hello everyone.
Welcome.
This is really exciting.
I am I'm very happy to
see so many people that
are interested in security.
So my name's Parisa.
Peter, thanks for the
awesome introduction.
And I get the honor of being
the master of ceremonies,
and to kick off our
security themed evening.
So we titled this event web
security, attack, defend,
and profit.
And myself and the
next three speakers
are going to each
touch on those topics.
So I work at Google.
And some of you may be
familiar with our company
motto, which is, don't be evil.
On the security team we
extend that to, don't be evil,
but do know evil.
And I'm going to
use this short intro
to talk a little bit
about why I think
it's really important
for developers
to occasionally embrace
the attacker mindset.
So I've worked at Google for
a little over seven years.
Currently I manage the
Chrome security team.
But when I started at
Google I was an engineer
in what we call the
hired hacker team.
And we had this broad
mission of doing whatever
we could to improve the security
of Google's web applications.
At the time, Google was
just a web app company.
Today we dabble in other things.
So one of the core
functions of this team
was to do information security
consulting, security design,
penetration testing.
And these are just
fancy ways of saying,
our job was to
break the software
that all of the other Google
engineers were building.
We were trying to find holes.
Ways to exploit the apps
that the people doing then
didn't think was possible or
didn't necessarily intend,
with the long term goal
of actually finding ways
to defend against that.
So in particular, we would try
to achieve some goal like theft
of information or assets, being
able to hijack some account
credentials and log into
an account we didn't own,
because this is a thread
we were and still are
most worried about at Google.
So as a developer, all of
you build applications.
This is a picture
from prior event.
And you all are
good people, and you
have the purest of intentions.
You create useful and
delightful applications
that make the world and
internet a better place.
And honestly, you
have my admiration.
Because it is so
much harder to build
robust and secure applications,
and software, than it
is to break them and find holes.
So you have my admiration
and my gratitude.
But the world is not only
filled with your kind.
And there are bad
guys, and bad girls,
that want to break your
applications and abuse holes
in your software, and attack
your users for personal profit
or gain.
And these are the people
that I worry about.
I worry about them
both as a user myself,
and on behalf of the users
of the software projects
that I'm involved with.
So to pull from my
copious knowledge
of ancient Chinese
military strategy,
I'm going to quote a
famous general, Sun Tzu,
and say, "To know your enemy,
you must become your enemy."
So if my personal experience
working in software
is worth anything, it's
that having experience
in breaking software and knowing
how to practically exploit
software will make you a better
developer of secure software.
It's one of the strongest
foundations you can have.
And I know that everybody here
wants to build secure software.
So take the black hat on, and
embrace the attacker mindset
for a moment.
So as I said, to
start the night off,
I want you to think about
breaking the software you use.
Breaking to suffer you write.
Find the holes.
Find the weaknesses.
And think of ways to exploit it.
Because I can assure
you that if you're
working on anything that's
successful or interesting,
other people will be
trying to do that.
So you may as well.
Only after you've totally tried
to break a piece of software
can you really have
confidence in its robustness
and its security.
So we have a training
for engineers at Google
that encourages this
attacker mindset.
And we often start off with
a non-software example.
I want to start us
off in the same way.
Suppose I tasked you with trying
to rip off a vending machine.
This vending machine, it's
in a large and crowded area.
We'll say it's an airport.
And I want you to get
out as many snacks
as you can for as little cost.
And do it without
getting caught.
So what would you do?
AUDIENCE: Walk up with a key.
PARISA TABRIZ:
Walk up with a key.
Where are you
getting a key from?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
it might change,
but social engineer
somebody else [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: OK.
Social engineering.
I like it.
Usually abusing the weakest
link, which unfortunately
sometimes is the
human, is successful.
So good answer.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Use a brick.
[LAUGHTER]
PARISA TABRIZ: Yes.
The sledgehammer attack
is often effective.
I want something a
little bit more stealthy.
AUDIENCE: Tell
security that there's
a bomb inside the airport.
PARISA TABRIZ: Oh.
Let's-- I saw one hand.
AUDIENCE: Dress up as
a maintenance person,
turn the machine on its side.
Take out the [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: How do
you turn the machine on?
AUDIENCE: No, on its side.
PARISA TABRIZ: Oh, turn
the machine on-- OK.
Sure.
We'll do-- Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Make a coin.
Make a counterfeit coin.
PARISA TABRIZ: OK.
Counterfeit coin, I like.
I actually have an image that--
this is my favorite attack.
If you search
online, there is tons
of resources on how to
hack into vending machines.
So there's resources
for how to abuse
the mechanical components.
And you can look up
the specific manual
for all of these different
vending machines.
You can find ways to abuse
the programming logic.
And even the
electrical components.
So, I have not
verified any of these.
I have no guarantee
that squirting salt
water in the coin
slot of a soda machine
will create an
electrical current that
can result in free soda.
I'm kind of doubting that
one, but this is the internet.
So who knows what to believe?
So someone suggested
counterfeit coins.
And this is actually one
of my favorite approaches.
It involves currency where
there is similar blanks,
or minting techniques, used for
multiple different currencies.
International currencies.
This is a picture of
the two Euro coin,
which is worth
approximately $2.70.
US dollars.
And here are a
couple of pictures
of coins that have successfully
fooled vending machines,
and are worth vastly less.
So we have the Thai baht at
about an eighth of the value.
The Mexican peso,
the Philippine peso.
There's actually a lot more
that have a very similar blank.
Coincidentally, I actually
was in Germany last week,
and I only realized
at the end of my trip
that someone had actually
given me a Thai baht, probably
as change at some
point during my trip.
Because I tried
paying for a snack,
and the cashier gave me
this really nasty look like,
this is not a two Euro.
So I can attest from first
hand that these attacks,
if not successful on a vending
machine, at least worked on me.
So, to be clear, I'm not
advocating that you go and rip
off vending machines.
Happily I think we have tons
of food if you're hungry,
and tons of booze.
And apologies to people
on the live stream.
But thinking through
possible ways
to attack a system,
whether it's a vending
machine or a piece of
software, will certainly
help you build in
better defenses
to some of those
threats and attacks.
And that's what
I'm encouraging you
to do as you build software.
So I don't know
if anybody in here
actually makes vending machines.
I assume you care
about web applications.
So we want to talk about
hacking web applications.
Has anyone heard of any common
types of web security bugs?
AUDIENCE: SQL injection.
PARISA TABRIZ: SQL injection.
Anything else?
Cross site scripting.
CSRF.
What does CSRF stand for?
AUDIENCE: Cross site
request forgery.
PARISA TABRIZ: Cross
site request forgery.
Awesome.
DDOS.
Distributed denial
of service attack.
Cool.
Any others?
AUDIENCE: SSL.
PARISA TABRIZ: SSL
is a security thing.
Maybe attacks to SSL?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: OK.
We've got lots.
I'm hearing lots of
things that are right,
or technologies
that can be abused.
So cross site scripting
is one that you're
going to hear a
couple times tonight.
It is the most common
type of web vulnerability.
It's the most common type
of reported vulnerability,
security bug, today.
And I say that with my
experience at Google.
So it's the most common security
bug we find in Google software.
It's also the most common bug
that's reported or disclosed
across industry today.
It's taken over buffer overflows
as the most common bug.
So the textbook definition.
Cross site scripting, it's
commonly abbreviated as XSS.
It's a vulnerability
that enables attackers
to execute malicious code within
the context of a vulnerable web
application.
So you get attacker gets
remote code execution
in a victim's session
of some web app.
So this is the
textbook definition.
Here are a bunch of headlines
that I found really quickly.
I cannot think of a single
application that I have used
that has not been vulnerable
at some point to a cross site
scripting bug.
This applies to
Google software, it
applies to lots of other
services that I use.
And Tim, our next
presenter, is actually
going to give you a
little bit more data
as to the scope of this problem.
But it's really an important
bug to understand, and to think
about when you're
building web apps.
So I gave you the textbook
definition of XSS.
And maybe some of you are
already familiar with this bug,
or have actually
thought about ways
to mitigate it in
apps you've run.
But the best way
to truly understand
the damage this
vulnerability can cause
is really to practice
finding them.
So just this
morning, we actually
launched two things which I
want to point everybody to,
and I encourage you to check
out after this event tonight.
Because they will really help
hone your hacking skills.
So the first is
interactive guide on XSS.
We'll see if links work.
They do.
So the URL on the slides, and of
course we'll share the slides,
will bring you to
this nice write up
of cross site scripting.
And you not only get a more
comprehensive description
of what cross site
scripting is, but really
nice interactive demos
where you can actually
try this out and see how it
works in little applications.
So you have this fake search
engine called Bobazillion.
And one of the most common ways
that a cross site scripting
flaw ends up being introduced
into a web application
is if the application is
handling user input, which
is untrusted input, and
not actually performing
the correct sanitization or
escaping before it actually
includes this input
in the response page.
So this first
example is actually
trying to guide you through
finding a cross site scripting
flaw as a user would type
input into a search engine.
OK.
So check out that.
Go learn XSS.
And once you learn
all about XSS,
you can check out this
other really fun thing
that we launched this morning,
which is the XSS war game.
I'll read off the
top. "Welcome recruit!
Cross site scripting
bugs are one
of the most common and dangerous
types of vulnerabilities
in web applications."
La-la-la.
"At Google, we know very well
how important these bugs.
In fact, Google is so serious
about finding and fixing XSS,
we are paying mercenaries
up to $7,500."
So this is true.
Tim's going to talk about
this again in the next talk,
but we reward researchers that
report cross site scripting
bugs, as well as a
bunch of other bugs.
And this is a great way
to practice finding them.
So, this is the first level.
And we'll actually
open this as well.
And you guys will all help me
go through the first level.
So cross site scripting.
We talked about them being the
most common and dangerous bugs.
In this training, you
will learn about this.
So if we go to level
one, "This level
demonstrates a
common cause of XSS,
where user input is directly
included in the page
without proper escaping.
Interact with the vulnerable
application window
below, and find a way
to make it execute
JavaScript of your choosing.
You can take actions inside
the vulnerable window,
or directly edit its URL bar."
So your objective
for this mission
is to inject a script to pop up
a JavaScript alert in the frame
below.
Typically, as a
security researcher,
you're trying to demonstrate,
hey, there's a bug
and I'm able to
actually execute code,
we'll use the alert function.
Because it's just a
very easy indication
that you're able to
perform something.
So that alert function
is a common way
to demonstrate a bug.
Once you show the
alert, you'll be
able to advance
to the next level.
OK.
So this actually looks
very similar to the demo
that I just showed.
We have some user input
here, and then we're
going to click Search.
And your goal is to
find the alert box.
Anybody have a solution?
Raise your hand.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Send my
[INAUDIBLE] alerts.
PARISA TABRIZ: OK.
So like this?
OK.
And then you want
me to click Search?
OK.
Anybody else?
I need a hand.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: Oops.
Script, alert.
You tell me if this looks right.
Like this?
Oops.
Is that what you want?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: OK.
We have a winner.
OK.
I could have passed something.
We alert undefined.
Good job.
OK.
So, with the help
of our friends--
I don't know your
name-- but everybody
has passed the first level.
And we can advance
to the next level.
And we're not going to
go through all these,
but they get increasingly
more challenging,
and it's a really
good way to practice
finding XSS and
understanding really
how complex these
bugs can actually be.
It's simple in theory,
but it's really hard
to eradicate them from web apps.
So check that out.
It's really fun.
And we'll go back to this.
Once you really master
XSS, you can check out
this interactive code lab.
This is actually a couple of
years old, but still totally
relevant.
It's called Gruyere.
And it also has crested
scripting bugs, as well
as a bunch of the other
types of common bugs
that you may have
heard mentioned
by people in the
audience before.
So there's cross site
request forgery, or CSRF.
There is some off bypass errors
in this bug, some mixed content
bugs.
Lots of different
common security bugs.
And the training will
not only describe
what the type of
vulnerability is,
but it will guide you through
exercises to find the bugs,
and also figure out
how to fix them.
Last book for anybody
who can tell me
why this is called Gruyere.
yes.
AUDIENCE: It's a type of cheese.
PARISA TABRIZ: Yes, it's a
type of cheese, but-- yeah,
in the blue shirt.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PARISA TABRIZ: Yes.
So, Gruyere is a
delicious cheese,
and it's also known for having
lots of little tiny holes.
I was afraid I was going to get
electronically zapped for going
outside the speaker zone.
So check this out.
This is going to help as
well hone your hacking skill.
Those are some excellent
resources to start.
After that, you
should be well suited
to start hacking on your own
software, or the software
that you use.
And all of this is-- I
mean have fun with it,
but also it's going to help you
build better software in terms
of defense.
And potentially
even profit, which
is what we're going to hear
about from our next speaker.
So I'm going to leave you with
much more qualified hands.
My three colleagues
at Google are
going to be speaking tonight.
Tim, Eduardo, and Joel.
Tim's up first.
Tim works at Google, and
among many other things,
he makes sure that
security bugs get
fixed, which is
actually really hard.
It's one thing to
find the bugs, it's
another thing to get them fixed.
So he spends his time working
with internal engineers
at Google, and also external
security researchers
that find and report bugs to us.
And before Google, Tim worked
in Australian department
of defense.
So he has come from
far away lands too,
to join us in the Bay Area.
So I'm going to
give it up to Tim.
Enjoy.
[APPLAUSE]